[Music]
being a part of something like this
there's a tremendous thing Browdy
[Music]
morning sergeant
gentlemen whoever's making these has an
answer for the deaths of 24 American
soldiers in the past 12 months and every
day we don't find them is another day an
American soldier could come home in
pieces and wants to make a difference
hey things are really taking off for me
how do you like it could bloody caveman
go gentlemen
what's the play relationship-building
starting new series who's ready to have
some fun
[Applause]
I just keep thinking about that day that
we killed it it moved wrong yeah I do
you kill one of theirs you save ten of
ours you're telling me that's not right
he didn't deserve to die her
co-operators hey Joe
tell me what's going on you know that
anything that happens to here stays in
the family
go get the targets we're gonna shoot you
or something you're trying to do what
you think is right
the problem is you don't even know what
right means leave me alone you are alone
do I do the right thing and put myself
in danger or do I just shut up and deal
with it
you give me your loyalty and I guarantee
that each and every one of you will have
a chance to be a war here to actually be
a part of history ready on three three
two one
[Applause]
[Music]